Narrator: We celebrate
the risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea‐makers...
We can really change
the world together.
Narrator: ...the ones who
determine their own fate.
‐Whoo!
‐We got a deal!
We celebrate entrepreneurs.
I want y'all to think ‐‐
who's next?
Narrator: This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight,
the American Dream continues.
Who wants to help Fidget Man
make Fidgetland
a household brand?
Barbara,
stay in your seat!
‐Aah!
‐Pull!
‐Whoa!
‐Oh!
You're scaring
the hell out of people
to cause them to buy something.
It's not a chachki
because it's functional.
There's a huge market
out there for our product.
‐What are your sales?
‐I've made almost $8,000.
Think of your next business
as fast as you can.
There's no business.
I'm going to give you
an offer.
‐Whoa!
‐You guys should
grab that money and run.
‐You're sassy.
‐Do you ever turn off?
Our counteroffer
is 25% equity.
You've got to
really get focused.
[ Sobs ]
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is an entrepreneur
at the forefront of a hot trend.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks! I'm Jason Burns.
I'm from Calabasas, California,
but I'm better known as
the Fidget Man from Fidgetland.
That's right.
I'm here seeking $50,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in my company, Fidgetland.
Like millions of people
around the world, I have A. D. D.
And I really have A. D. D.
Not like "Oh, he has A. D. D."
I really have A. D. D.
[ Laughter ]
Which means I have a hard time
focusing and I'm full of energy.
I'm sure you know people
like me, and unfortunately,
you're familiar with
some of our annoying habits.
Things like bouncing knees,
tapping pencils, clicking pens,
nail biting, hair twirling.
The list goes on and on and on.
Well, let me tell you ‐‐
we do these annoying,
fidgety‐type habits to help us
burn off excess energy
and to keep the part of our
brain that gets bored occupied
so the other part can
pay attention and focus.
But even though
these habits might help us,
they're extremely distracting
and drive people
around us crazy.
I can't tell you how many times
I've been on a plane
or in a meeting
and someone's told me
to stop bouncing my knee.
I'm that guy.
Well, I was that guy,
until I created
a line of products
that burns excess energy,
keeps your brain occupied
and focused,
and most importantly, doesn't
disturb the people around you.
Because our products
are discreet.
So discreet you didn't realize
I've had one in my hand
this entire time.
And amazingly, our products
aren't just for A.D.D.ers.
They're also used to help with
diagnosed disorders like autism,
Asperger's, Tourette's,
as well as non‐diagnosed,
like stress and anxiety.
And, Sharks,
our fidgets really work.
There's a huge market
out there for our products,
but we need our help
to put our fidgets
into the hands of millions
of people around the world.
So who wants
to help the Fidget Man
make Fidgetland
a household brand?
I have some samples.
Let me pass them out so you guys
can get fidgeting.
‐Okay.
He didn't look so fidgety to me.
Did he to you?
‐He didn't look very fidgety.
‐That's 'cause he's got
the fidget device.
‐That's right.
‐There you go.
‐Thank you, Fidget Man.
‐Absolutely. For you.
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you, Fidget Man.
‐Fidget Man from Fidgetland.
Can we just rip
this out of here?
‐Yes, take it out.
‐Thank you, Jason.
‐There you go.
‐Thank you.
Is it all the same design,
all of them?
Burns: No. So we have
eight different models.
So each of you have two,
and then I have other models
up here if you guys
want to try them.
But basically,
just put it in your hand,
and it'll come naturally.
Just let it roll in your fingers
and play with it.
You had it on your thumb.
Is that what you're...
I just had it on my thumb
just to hold it,
but there's no wrong way
to play with it at all.
Jason, how did you
create your first one?
When I was in 11th grade,
I was diagnosed with A. D. D.,
and the woman who diagnosed me
said that my A. D. D.
was so severe that I would
never be able to survive
at a four‐year university
and I shouldn't try to pursue
a job that required
any type of education.
I was fortunate enough
that my pediatrician
was somewhat
of an expert in A. D. D.
And this is back in 1988.
So he put me on medicine,
and overnight, my life changed.
And it was the first time
I could ever
pay attention in school.
And my grades started to,
you know, literally
go through the roof.
And it was the first time
I could pay attention.
I graduated from
the University of Arizona
in four years with a 3.4 GPA.
‐Good for you. Wow.
‐That's great.
And I majored in business
and then went to work
in entertainment.
I worked in the entertainment
industry for over 20 years.
And it was when
I was working in production ‐‐
I always needed something
to stop my knee from bouncing,
and so, ever since
I was a little kid,
I've always invented and made
things out of other things.
And so first thing I, you know,
went and looked in the garage
to see what we had.
We had bike chain.
I look some bike chain...
‐Oh.
‐...took some key rings,
and put it together, and that's
how I made my first one.
How long have you
been in business?
I made my first
fidget in 2007.
Since 2007, how many
of these have you sold?
A little over 50,000 of them.
And how much
in dollars is that?
A little north of $500,000.
Well, you have my respect.
That's more than
I expected you to say.
This year, how many
of these will you sell?
We're on track
to do over $500,000 this year.
‐In this?
‐Fidget's hot right now.
I started making these
just for myself,
and I put a couple on eBay
and gave them to friends,
and year after year,
all through word of mouth,
it just kind of
kept going and going.
So you're doing
this full‐time.
I do this full‐time, yeah.
I quit my career,
and I've been the Fidget Man
from Fidgetland ever since.
What do you
sell them for?
So they range in price
from between $8 and $15.
And our cost to make them ranges
between $1.35 and $2.69.
So we have 80% markup.
‐I can't imagine there's not
a ton of competitors.
Yeah, they're ‐‐ yes,
there are competitors.
And people have knocked me off.
I have to tell you ‐‐
I mean, it's very soothing.
It's really cool.
Jason, how are you gonna
sell half a million?
Is it just online?
So, yeah.
Right now,
we're about 85% online,
through our website
and through Amazon.
But primarily on the web.
How do people find you?
Our growth has been pretty
phenomenal and amazing.
My first year doing it
full‐time, we did $88,000.
And then,
since I've done it full‐time,
we've done $371,000 in sales.
Now, is a lot of it
people searching for "fidget"
and "fidget spinners"
and then seeing you
and seeing you
as a valid alternative?
Yeah, more or less.
You're not
buying ads today.
I just hired
a digital marketing company
to help me with advertising.
'Cause up until now ‐‐
So you've got to be
making a lot of money.
What do you expect your
net profit to be this year?
$175,000.
Why not more?
'Cause you said you were
gonna do $500,000 in sales.
We'll do $500,000.
Yeah, your margins
are 70‐plus percent.
‐Right.
‐He's buying advertising.
‐Well, yeah.
‐Well, no, he said he wasn't.
‐No, this year we will.
‐You're going to? Okay.
Look, what you've accomplished
is wonderful and amazing,
but I don't know
how I could help this,
because it's a specialty
market trying to convert
to a wider base
of a market.
That's not a sale
that I think
is gonna play
to my strengths.
So for those
reasons, I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
You seem lovely.
Yes.
I love your story
of overcoming the hardships.
Um, just personally...
For me, tactilely,
touching this,
I'm not having like,
a good fidget experience.
‐So let me...
‐[ Laughs ]
Here's the thing ‐‐
that's part of what's,
and I don't mean to cut you off,
but part of fidgeting is,
and I call myself a fidget
whisperer in a sense,
everyone fidgets differently,
and what one person
might like
somebody else might not.
I don't think I'm a fair
judge of this because
I'm not the person
that would sit and fidget.
It's just not me.
I'm out.
‐Jason...
‐Yes?
I just have to admit,
it's a little infectious.
I've been messing around with it
since you got out here.
And as I'm fidgeting,
I'm trying to think
what the multiple is
for public fidget companies.
[ Laughter ]
What did the last one
trade at, Kevin?
Exactly.
It's just ‐‐
It's too small.
It's too small for me.
I admire what
you've done, and...
‐Thank you.
‐...at the end of the day,
look, I appreciate the
opportunity to learn the story.
But it's not for me.
I'm out.
All righty. Uh, I think for ‐‐
what's important is that it's,
like I said, we're in
the special‐needs market,
but I think there's a much
broader market out there for us.
Corcoran: I have a child
who's 11, and she's A. D. D.
And she's got
the wiggle leg thing,
which I actually
don't find annoying,
but I'm crazy about her.
This is kind of
a cause for me.
Okay.
I love these A. D. D. types,
and half of them
are real geniuses
if only you could find a good
slot to put them in, right?
And my most productive people
that I've worked with
my whole life usually have some
kind of a curveball in learning,
and I seek them out.
In fact, if I were to make
a list of my top, say,
seven or eight entrepreneurs
I've invested in
on "Shark Tank," I would say
all but one have
a learning disability,
so it's a turn‐on for me.
I hear somebody's got
a learning disability,
and they're my people,
so to speak,
and probably because
I was so terribly abused
in school as the dumb kid.
Right. Yes.
I'm gonna make you,
of course your $50,000 offer,
but for 20%.
But the $50,000 has to be spent
entirely on marketing costs.
Entirely marketing costs.
It's well‐calculated...
Right.
...well‐planned‐out,
and we do it together.
Right.
Because I don't want
anything thrown up
against a board.
It's not a lot of money,
but I want it well‐spent.
Got it.
I'd love the opportunity
to tell you where I am.
Please.
All right.
So, I come from a time,
'cause I'm very old,
where they didn't
diagnose A. D. D.
They called you hyperactive.
And that's what I was.
And it is
incredibly infectious.
I've been sitting here
the whole time.
I haven't been able
to put it down.
I usually shake my leg
when I'm up here,
and it's really
kind of calmed me down.
I'll give you $50,000 for...
What did you offer?
I said 20%.
I'll give it to you for 15%.
Whoa!
Narrator: Three Sharks are out.
Jason has two offers on the
table, from Barbara and Robert,
for his fidget toy company,
Fidgetland.
I'll give you $50,000 for...
What did you offer?
I said 20%.
I'll give it to you for 15%.
‐Ooh.
‐Whoa!
‐Undercut her.
‐Who would've thunk it?
You came in here
with a bicycle chain
and an elastic band,
and you've got two offers.
This is amazing.
Uh, this is so fun.
I have to tell you.
This is like, the greatest.
This is so awesome.
Jason, you've got to get ‐‐
you've got to really
get focused.
‐This is amazing.
‐Yeah.
‐Maybe you need a fidget.
‐And so you've got to
make a decision.
‐I always have many fidgets.
‐I got three.
‐With all due respect to Robert,
okay, he's had that experience,
he's had the same issue,
but I'm a little bit more
steeped in it, honestly, okay?
I'm the poster child
of the kid that made good,
who had a real severe
learning disability.
So, Barbara, are you
willing to match his 15%?
I've got a kid
that graduated from
an Ivy League school
who couldn't read
till he was 10 because
I outwitted the system
and figured out how he was
gonna become a superstar.
And now I have another
kid down the pike
who I have
to pour myself into.
Barbara, stop selling.
Let him make a decision.
No, no. What they have in common
is a passionate mother.
I treat my businesses as though
they are my children.
My entrepreneurs don't fail
unless there's nothing else
I can do to let them not fail.
So, you'd be actually
out of your mind
to take the offer from him.
Yeah, I ‐‐
But go right ahead.
Barbara's
an incredible woman.
She has an incredible family,
and obviously this is
a great cause,
but you know,
with all due respect
to Barbara,
I also see it
as a great business.
And I'm not gonna share my level
of knowledge about the space,
and I think I can support you
on that and help you with it.
Plus, I don't need to take
20% of your business.
You've got to make a decision.
This is your moment.
Barbara,
would you consider 15%?
I don't think so, no.
Barbara, I would
love to do a deal.
‐You're a smart guy.
‐Bingo.
‐Congrats, Barb.
‐Okay.
‐Congrats.
‐Thank you so much.
I'm gonna need
more fidgeters.
‐Thank you so much.
‐I hope you remember,
you did the deal with me.
You remember?
‐Are you kidding?
‐Good.
[ Laughter ]
That's who I wanted
to do it with.
Oh, yeah?
You're full of crap.
‐Congratulations.
‐I appreciate it.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Congratulations, Jason.
Thank you. Whoo‐hoo!
That's awesome!
I'll give it a heel‐tap.
Whoo‐hoo!
I'm just ‐‐
I'm through the roof.
I just can't believe
that they got it.
And to me, that was what
I hoped was
that people would
get what it is.
And they got it.
And to get two offers
in "Shark Tank" is amazing.
I'm just like ‐‐
this is the greatest.
It's the greatest day.
It's amazing.
♪♪
Narrator: In season 8,
ophthalmologist Tara Brown
made a deal with Lori Greiner
for her hair‐styling product,
the Sleep Styler.
I'm gonna make you an offer
of $75,000 for 30%.
‐25%?
‐Done!
Let's see what she's up to now.
Brown: Within
five minutes of airing,
I had sold out
of all of my inventory.
In the first 24 hours
after "Shark Tank,"
I did $1.5 million in sales.
Lori immediately
got the product on to QVC,
where we sold out
in just minutes.
She was able to get
the Sleep Styler in front of
Walmart and Bed Bath & Beyond
and secure
a nationwide rollout.
Just three months later,
we just passed
the $50 million
in retail sales mark.
Hi, guys!
Hi, Lori!
Greiner: The response after
the Sleep Styler aired
was unbelievable.
I've never hit this kind of
number in that amount of time
with any of my
"Shark Tank" entrepreneurs.
Brown:
Business has been amazing,
but I have been struggling
to keep my head above water.
I'm still a working mom with
my ophthalmology practice.
I could really use Lori's help.
We are going to
take over for you.
All of the manufacturing,
the fulfillment.
You can now just do
what you love to do.
We came up
with a great plan.
I'll have more time
to spend with my kids
and on my medical practice
while still being involved
with the big picture.
[ Both gasp ]
Oh, my gosh!
There it is!
This is gorgeous.
Greiner:
Our goal is world domination.
We want every woman
who wants gorgeous hair
and no damage to be able
to get a Sleep Styler.
Wait. We got to be
the first to buy one.
All right!
Brown: Two years ago,
this was just an idea,
and now thanks to Lori, I have
millions of dollars in sales.
This is a dream come true.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a safer version of something
we wear every day.
♪♪
Hi, I'm Brighton Jones.
And I'm Aaron Dalley.
We're from
Salt Lake City, Utah,
and we're the founders
of Enso Rings.
We're seeking $500,000
in exchange for 7.5%
of our product that's disrupting
the jewelry industry.
Sharks, do you know
what this is?
If you're thinking
"wedding ring," you're wrong.
It's an F. A. D. ‐‐
a finger amputation device.
It might sound crazy,
but it's true.
Yeah.
Whether you're at the gym,
on the job,
or simply unloading your car,
at any moment, your ring
could catch on something
and severely damage your finger,
or even rip it right off.
It's called ring avulsion,
and it happens to over 150,000
people per year.
Enso Rings are made
of a proprietary silicone
that's engineered
to take a beating
and adapt to your
active lifestyle.
And most importantly,
they're designed to break away
when caught on something.
In short, Enso Rings
are the most stylish,
safe alternative to metal rings
and wedding bands.
Sharks, this is
a standard metal band.
Just like the ones
you're wearing right now.
And this...
is award‐winning professional
body builder Garrett Coelho.
That, my dear, is a man.
Barbara, stay in your seat.
Aah!
His biceps represent over
500 pounds of pulling force,
which is more than enough
to tear your finger right off.
Garrett, what do you say
we show them what happens
when their ring
gets caught on something?
Pull!
‐Ohh!
‐Ugh!
‐Wow!
‐Oh, my God!
‐Now, let's try that again,
with a real finger on a human
hand and an Enso Ring.
Jones: And let's
up the stakes this time
and triple
the pulling power.
Luke, Darnell,
come on out!
‐Oh, God!
‐Now, what about this, Lori?
‐[ Laughs ]
‐And please, whatever you do,
do not try this at home.
All right,
you guys ready?
In 3, 2, 1 ‐‐ pull!
Oh, yes.
And that's the power
of an Enso Ring.
So it just broke.
‐It just came apart.
‐Thank you, guys.
I appreciate it.
‐Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I don't believe it.
Let's do it again.
[ Laughter ]
Dalley: Well, that's the thing.
We'll probably need to
dismiss these guys so you'll
stop staring at their biceps
and listen to the rest
of our presentation, so...
Corcoran: Thank you,
gentlemen. Thank you.
[ Blows kiss ]
Jones: All right, Sharks. We
brought samples for each of you.
Robert.
‐Here we go, Barbara.
‐So what you're looking at
is a specially curated
selection of our rings.
You have different options.
‐Thank you.
‐The ones on your right...
‐Thanks. Appreciate it.
...are loose rings that
we took a guess were your sizes,
so you can try those on.
Most people tell us that
30 seconds after they put it on,
they forget that
it's even there.
‐They're all plastic?
‐They're made of silicone.
That's silicone rubber.
Okay, so in America,
how many people do you think
get up in the morning
and say,
"Wow, I hope my finger
doesn't get ripped off
when I catch my ring in a rope
pulled by a guy
from Mount Zeus"?
Zero.
But that's the problem.
That is a big problem.
You don't have it
when you need it.
How do you get anybody even
interested in understanding
why they need an Enso Ring?
150,000 people
in the U. S. alone, per year,
have a ring‐avulsion
accident.
And that's your
opening marketing...
But how many of those people
get their fingers ripped off
versus pulled, strained?
You guys might've
seen Jimmy Fallon's.
It took him off the air
for two weeks.
He was walking in his kitchen,
tripped on the rug,
ring gets caught
on the countertop,
and nearly tears the finger off.
Wow.
If you have
an active lifestyle,
you're constantly taking
your ring off, putting it on.
And we haven't even talked
about all the applications.
These are really
popular among nurses.
They match their scrubs.
We're talking about
firefighters, electricians,
physicians, the military.
They can't wear metal rings.
Tell us about you,
how you came to do this.
Sure.
Brighton and I,
we've been friends
pretty much our whole lives,
and we've always wanted
to start a business together.
A few years ago, I had
a rock‐climbing accident.
I fell,
and on the way down,
my wedding ring
got caught on the rock.
And there was
that split second ‐‐
Why would you even
wear a wedding ring
while you're climbing?
It's not something
you think about.
You don't wake up
in the morning and say,
"My finger's gonna
get torn off."
I always take my ring off
when I'm working out,
playing basketball.
Dalley:
Not everybody does, though.
Some people just forget about
it, don't think about it.
What do you actually
sell one ring for?
Anywhere from
$11.99 to $39.99.
Herjavec: And what does
it cost you to make it?
It ranges from 70 cents
up to $4.00.
Wow. I'm gonna guess,
you guys have a ton of sales.
Actually, in the past
18 months,
we've done $3.8 million
in sales.
Whoa.
Unbelievable.
I knew it.
This year, we're projected to do
a little over $5 million.
What?
So on the $11.99 ring,
this one I guess,
it costs you 70 cents?
Correct.
[ Laughs ] I love this.
And you sell this one for a man,
which is the largest,
for how much?
‐$39.99.
‐$39.
‐How much does that one cost?
‐That one costs anywhere
from $2 to $4.
Why would that cost $4?
We wanted to get a band
that looked like a metal ring.
Everything out there,
we thought looked cheap.
We use actual gold on the gold
ring, so it gets expensive.
It has elements of gold ‐‐
flecks of gold in it?
‐It does.
‐Wow.
I respect sales.
Doesn't matter what I think,
it matters what
the market thinks.
And I'm very impressed.
Where are you selling them?
It's all through the dot‐com
and marketplaces right now.
So it's all online.
It's been an amazing
social‐media push.
You're real expense
is customer acquisition,
'cause you're
selling online, right?
And it's a fear sale.
So you're scaring
the hell out of people
to cause them
to buy something.
So this last month,
what were your sales?
What did you spend
on marketing?
Yeah.
Last month, best month ever.
$460,000
in sales last month.
Okay.
We spent about 40%
on average.
You guys will spend
$2 million‐plus
in advertising
and marketing?
Sure.
You guys are a marketing company
that just found a product.
That's not a bad thing.
And you're
obviously good at it.
But I just ‐‐
scaring the hell out of people
that their finger
might get yanked off,
I just don't see that
as a long‐term business.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
This fear‐based aspect
is what we started with,
because that's
what we understood.
But our largest
market right now,
it's about it being
a jewelry trend.
Here ‐‐ Here's the thing.
I'm familiar
with silicone because
I make a lot of products
in silicone.
There's just tons
of these out there.
So I'm not taking away
that you don't have great sales,
because you do have
great sales.
But as an investor,
when I look at something,
I look at what's out there
and then I think about,
what's gonna be
the likelihood
making my return
on my investment.
While you might be great
and your sales are great,
I think it's a little dicey
because there's so much
competition.
But our model ‐‐
For those reasons,
I'm sorry, I'm out.
Thanks, Lori.
I find your messaging
is mixed up.
I'm not sure it's
a message ‐‐ save your finger,
or ‐‐ this is
a fashion statement.
And trying to relay
both of those,
and even in your packaging,
I don't see that messaging,
so I don't find that clarity
that's gonna hook in
the customer that you want.
So with your great
presentation skills,
I say think of your next
business as fast as you can.
I'm out.
[ Robert laughs ]
I like to think,
probably arrogantly, that
I understand a little bit
about every business.
There's been a couple
of times in nine seasons,
people have come out,
and I'm sitting here,
and I'm going, "I have no clue
why people are buying this."
That was Tipsy Elves,
and it was Sand Cloud.
Tipsy Elves was
$72 million this year.
‐Wow.
‐What I learned in investing
in those guys is ‐‐
there was a message
behind their product even they
didn't understand at the time.
So sometimes your consumers
tell you and create the message.
Barb is dead‐on.
Your message
is very confusing.
But $5 million worth
of customers can't be wrong.
So I'll make you an offer.
‐You're kidding!
‐Robert?
You're really losing it,
Robert.
These guys are great.
I love these guys.
I'll give you
the $500,000 for...
...20%.
It's a pure flyer for me.
Your offer is $500K
for 20%.
Thank you, Kevin. I can speak
for myself, you know?
Okay, because I, too,
have an offer.
$500,000 for...
I, too, have an offer
that you should hear.
Kevin, I can
speak for myself.
I find you
exceedingly greedy.
Let me give you an alternative.
When you walked in here,
you pitched us on this
$6 million‐plus valuation.
I was gonna give you
the finger,
but now I'm wearing your ring,
and I'm feeling the love.
I really like it.
To me, the opportunity here
is to leverage that platform,
you call the Something Wonderful
platform, to reduce
customer‐acquisition costs.
And I've got millions
of customers.
I'm gonna give you
the $500,000 as a loan.
And because you can afford it,
you're gonna pay me $2 per order
until I make back $1.5 million,
then it goes away.
And I was 5% equity
to be your banker
and the person that provides you
help in customer acquisition.
I would consider
a counter.
Okay, thank you very much.
So you see something in it.
There's something here
for sure.
I'd feel a lot better
if one of you knew
what the something was.
I'm okay with that.
I mean, if you're gonna
stand there and say "We're only
rings," there's no business.
No. I like that. Thank you.
Would you be willing to do 10%?
[ Chuckles ]
Uh, no.
But let's talk about
the evaluation, I guess.
Where are we coming up short
with the numbers
we gave you initially?
Are you kidding?
The risk is huge.
It's just
risk/comfort thing.
But here's what
I will do.
I'll split the difference
between the 10% and the 20%.
I'll do it at 15%.
You guys should grab
that money and run. My God.
Cuban: Are you kidding me?
You guys are crazy to take that.
If you believe what you've said,
you're crazy to take it.
Dalley:
You want to do it?
12.5%?
Herjavec:
No, I'm gonna stick at 15%.
Okay. The last thing
would be ‐‐
do you guys have interest
in something together?
'Cause the wedding platform
is big for us.
Not just the engagement side,
but then also we get people
buying for, like,
their bridesmaids.
O'Leary: Are you thinking
through my offer?
It costs you a lot less
if you're actually
gonna be successful.
Because it goes away
after basically 30 months.
I've already done the math.
I don't want
to play with Kevin.
[ Laughs ] Okay.
I think access to the platform
is worth something,
but, also, if you
really think through my offer,
it costs you a lot less
if you believe
you're gonna be successful.
You guys are gonna
figure it out.
$500,000, 15%.
Maybe they're
smart guys.
They're smart guys,
no doubt.
They're definitely
smart guys.
[ Sighs ] Kevin, thank you
very much for the offer.
‐Uh‐oh.
‐We're going to go ahead
and take Robert's.
Yes!
‐Congratulations.
‐Thank you.
Thank you.
That was awesome.
I don't understand it,
but I'm so excited.
We'll explain it to you
along the way.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Appreciate your time.
Yes.
Yes, brother!
We did it!
Yeah, "Shark Tank"!
It's possibly Kevin's would have
worked out better financially,
but Enso's a force for good,
and Robert's someone
who gets that.
It's incredible.
You could
see it in his eyes
from the beginning,
he was into it.
We love that kind of passion.
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a product
to make a favorite
beverage even better.
♪♪
Hi. My name
is Charles Nick.
My name's Taylor Minor,
from Cedarville, Ohio.
We're seeking $100,000
for 10% interest in our company,
Third Wave Water.
I own a coffee shop,
and my customers
constantly ask me
how the coffee
that they brew at home
can taste just as delicious
as it does in the cafe.
Eager aficionados
can buy the best beans,
grind fresh daily,
use the best drip systems,
and still not come close
to tasting as good.
You don't need
expensive contraptions,
you need the right water.
You're delicious cup of coffee
consists of 98% water,
so it's so important
that you use the right
type of water
when you brew.
So what is
the right water, you ask?
Well, it's a delicate balance
of minerals in the water
that make it perfect
for brewing.
Mini cafes install large,
complex water systems
just to make
perfect brewing water.
Well, that's simply not
practical for home use.
That's why we created
Third Wave Water.
Simply add this stick
of precise minerals
to a gallon of distilled water,
and you're ready to brew.
We've shipped to over
50 countries and all 50 states.
Many of those customers have
stated that they will never
go back to brewing coffee
with any other water again.
Join us as we help
coffee drinkers around the world
finally experience coffee
like it was meant to be.
Sharks,
who's ready for coffee?
‐Bring it on.
‐Yeah, bring it on.
So, this is Dylan.
He won the U. S. Brewers Cup
using Third Wave Water.
‐Did he really?
‐There's a U. S. Brewers Cup?
There is.
And he won the U. S. Brewers Cup
using Third Wave Water.
‐Grazie.
‐Here's the Third Wave Water.
And L. A. tap water.
Thank you very much.
Oh, you have two?
Bad water and your water.
‐Yes, sir.
‐So in the black cup,
that's local L. A. tap water.
‐So let us all try that first.
‐Wow.
‐Yeah.
‐Now, that's good L. A.
‐That sucks, that coffee.
‐It's horrible.
‐Let's be real here.
‐Now I'm trying the...
‐It's horrible.
‐I'm trying
the Third Wave Water.
‐Third Wave Water.
So one packet mixed
into a gallon of water.
It's smoother.
I must admit,
this is better.
It's less acrid.
It has a longer finish...
It's smoother.
...for sure.
It's smoother,
and is it acidity?
‐Correct.
‐Is it affecting the acidity?
‐Yes.
‐Tell us what's in the powder.
Minor: Well, let me give you
a little background on myself.
So I joined ‐‐
‐We don't care.
We just care
about the powder.
You need to hear
about me first.
The magic powder, man.
So, I joined the Marine Corps
right out of high school,
spent a year in Iraq
as a machine‐gunner.
In 2004, came back, got married,
started a coffee shop.
‐Thank you for your service.
‐Thank you.
‐Yes, absolutely.
‐Started a coffee shop.
My customers would always
ruin the coffee
that I'm giving them
with their tap water.
And I kept trying
to figure out a way
to make perfect brewing water.
Now, I know as a winemaker,
distilled water tastes terrible.
‐Absolutely.
‐Yes.
It's not that easy to get
anymore, pure distilled water.
But what happens if
I just use tap water?
It's not gonna do it.
You can't.
The problem is, tap water,
from city to city...
Too much iron in it, right?
Well, it's gonna have ‐‐
who knows what's in it.
It depends on the rainfall,
it depends on what
stone is underneath.
Wait, but let's go back,
'cause I'm confused about this,
for a minute.
I'm confused, too.
So in the stores,
they sell all types of water ‐‐
spring water,
distilled water.
What you're saying is
that you need to take
one of these packets,
put it into distilled water,
then put that
into your coffee maker.
Yes.
Guys, talk us
through the numbers.
We've been in business
for eight months,
and we have over 1,200 customers
shipped to over 50 countries.
‐What are your total sales?
‐Sales?
We've done
$66,000 this year.
We did $4,000 last year.
Around the world?
‐Around the world.
How much do you think you'll do
for the entire year?
$120,000
is our estimate.
You know, at first I thought
that this was, like, your little
pack that you would
just pour into your...
Yeah, me too.
...individual coffee,
and I thought, "Oh, well, if it
makes my coffee taste better,
and it's minerals,
which is healthy,
then that might be
a great thing."
But the complication of it,
that I have to pour this
into only distilled water,
makes a really complicated
solution to something that
isn't that big of a problem.
And so unfortunately,
for that reason, I'm out.
Thank you for your
consideration.
I'm with Lori.
I thought you had something
that I could conveniently
put in my cup in the morning
to enhance the experience.
The coffee tastes great.
But fancy for me is when I use
bottled water in my coffee.
It's not for me.
Appreciate the cup.
I'm out.
Guys, I ‐‐
this is...a hard sale.
O'Leary: But there is
a market for it.
The question is,
how big is that market,
and how expensive
is it to access it?
Because I have to admit,
this is amazing coffee.
I mean, compared to what the
street water tasted versus this.
I've been buying wine
as an investor for decades.
Why does everything
come back to wine?
Well, you got to hear this out.
You'll learn something, Barbara.
It's so boring.
Listen, grasshopper.
I never learn
anything from you.
I'm gonna bring
it home for you.
I've not learned
a single thing from you.
I just want you to know.
You're gonna learn
something very important.
how to listen...
Get on with it, get out.
...from the master, all right?
Better have some coffee
to stay awake for this.
And then I started
doing the research,
and here's what I learned.
I thought I could bring wine
out at $60, $80, $90 a bottle,
have no trouble
getting market share.
When I went to the retailers,
they told me that 97%
of wine sold in America
is sold for under $12 a bottle.
That is 97% of the market.
So I think where you fit ‐‐
you're in that 3% niche
of people that are willing
to pay and go through the hassle
of making this perfect
cup of coffee.
It's very difficult to make it
a mass‐based product.
I cannot figure out here how...
So I'll throw this out
for you to think about.
...I go from $66,000 in sales,
or even $120,000,
and ever get my $100,000 back.
I mean, that's the problem.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I'm out.
Thank you,
Mr. Wonderful.
One of the great aspects
is our gross margins are 95%.
So we send these packs
for free to people
so we can get it
in their home.
Cuban: No one's questioning
whether it can work.
You've proved it.
It tastes better.
Yes. The problem is,
how much work,
how much hassle factor
is required to get there.
Anything that can enhance
the coffee market
has a great opportunity,
but it's so niche.
Sorry, guys.
For those reasons, I'm out.
‐We appreciate it, Mark.
‐Thank you.
Herjavec: Charles,
you still got Barbara.
You know, sadly for me,
there's a lot I see wrong here.
I think buying a gallon
of distilled water
and carrying it home, that's
asking a lot of a consumer.
It's a royal pain in the ass.
And if I was using
my left brain and my logic,
I would just be out right away.
But there's something
about you guys I really like.
I think you're
straight shooters.
This coffee tasted
twice as good as the other cup.
I mean, everybody here
responded the same way.
True.
I'll offer you $100,000
for 33.33%.
[ Lori groans ]
Plus, I want $1 per box sold
until I recoup my $100,000.
It's aggressive. I have to
admit, it's very aggressive.
You can counter.
That dollar is a royalty,
Barbara.
Excuse me, would you just
be quiet for a while?
It's a royalty.
Call it what you want.
Nasty.
Barbara, I want to know
what you think that you can do
specifically that's gonna
help our company.
I'm gonna know
how to market it.
You're gonna get
tons of repeat orders.
But I think your
marketplace is online.
And I can help you there because
I sell so much product online.
♪♪
Our counteroffer is
25% equity,
still have
the $100,000 loan
that's repaid back
with $1 per pack.
So instead of 33.33%,
you're giving me 25%?
Yes.
I would happily take that
because, you know what,
that's actually
what I wanted.
‐Thank you.
‐There you go, Barbara.
Congratulations.
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐Thank you very much.
Come and give me
a double hug.
Double hug.
Good luck, guys.
Very impressive.
‐Congrats, guys.
‐Thank you.
Thank you.
Bam!
Minor: Not only did we get
great advice from some of
the best business people
in America,
but we got a deal
with one of the Sharks,
and we are super happy.
Martin: [ Whispering ]
You are creative,
you are unique,
you are awesome.
You are creative,
Narrator: Next up is a mom with
a solution to a hairy problem.
♪♪
[ Chuckles ]
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Liz Martin
from Battle Ground, Washington,
and I am here today asking
for $75,000 in exchange for
35% of my company.
Sharks, every day,
parents are put face‐to‐face
with an exhausting and seemingly
impossible challenge.
Wow.
[ Laughs ]
Wait.
Hair.
Getting a small child
to sit still long enough
to brush their hair
is one of humanity's
most vexing challenges.
[ Laughs ]
I'm a mother of three girls,
so I know...
brushtration is real!
And as I searched
for a solution,
I was only met
with more...
medieval torture devices
that sent my kiddos running.
Finally, I found a solution.
It was in my daughter's bedroom,
staring right back at me.
I present to you...
the TanglePets!
[ Laughter ]
It's a high‐quality
hairbrush placed inside
a ridiculously adorable
plush character,
making kids love it,
parents need it.
So, Sharks, who is ready
to get fierce on tangles
while staying
friendly with kids?
I have samples!
[ Laughter ]
Blue lion for you, Mark.
Thank you.
‐What did you get, Mark?
‐I got a blue lion.
‐Ladybug for you, Lori.
‐Thank you.
‐What did you get, Lori?
‐Ladybug.
‐Turtle for you, Kevin.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Nice to meet you.
‐A turtle for Kevin.
‐Barb.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Sassy kitty.
‐Aww.
‐And a puppy.
‐Aww! Thank you!
‐So, tell us about
your background first.
So I've always been
a salesperson,
and I've always loved
finding good products and then,
you know, getting people
to buy them.
When I became a mom,
my focus shifted obviously.
My kids were playing
in their room one day,
but as I walked in, I saw
all these toys on the ground.
I literally went in, like,
snuck a toy,
very disturbingly shoved
a brush in it,
and then like, I'm like,
around the corner
like [high‐pitched voice]
"Hey, everybody,
who wants to brush their hair?"
And like, game‐changer
at that point. No joke.
But this is
an ordinary brush
with a hippopotamus
attached to it.
I would not say ordinary,
because I will tell you,
I spent ‐‐
No, but is it because it's
a hippo that the kids like
the fact that it's a toy?
Because it's a brush.
No, no, no. Let me explain
something about brushes.
What do you mean, "No, no, no."
I'm looking. That's a brush.
I get that you're looking at
it ‐‐ you're not feeling it,
and you don't have hair
to brush it with.
‐Ohh!
‐Ka‐boom!
‐No, that's not ‐‐
that's a good thing!
‐Excuse me...
‐I love people without hair!
‐Are you kidding me?
‐Whoa!
Trust me, there is
so much hair on his back,
he'll put this to use.
‐Ohh!
‐It's true though. It's true.
What I really want to know,
is this any different
than any other brush
I can buy for 5 cents?
It absolutely is.
You are sassy.
I like it.
No, stay on the brush.
You're telling me there's
nothing like this?
Do you have
a patent on it?
‐Provisional utility patent.
‐You've got to be kidding.
No, that particular
brush is unique?
What, you're saying
this brush is patentable?
This specific brush
says that it's meant
for all hair types,
and it is.
Do you make this brush?
Or you borrowed this brush
and put the animal on top?
No, no, no.
I have it made in China.
What does it cost?
So it's $2.60 landed.
I wholesale for $5,
and it retails for $12.
Okay, that's great.
I've made almost $8,000.
Whoa!
$8,000!
Maybe she's only been
selling for a short time.
‐How long have you been selling?
‐How many years?
So I ‐‐ no, I had
the idea last year.
I got my first shipment
in November.
What happened was ‐‐ here's what
you got to understand about me.
‐So ‐‐
‐Listen, if this keeps
going this way, you're gonna
make hundreds of dollars here.
I know!
Let me explain.
My husband got diagnosed
with a brain disease last year.
And so I have to be honest
with you ‐‐ I knew
this was gonna be big,
but I also knew I had
to take care of my husband and I
had to take care of my kids.
And that's why
the sales are $8,000.
And I'm not making excuses,
but that was my focus.
I promise you when
sales are the focus ‐‐
My focus is now that. My husband
is healthy, things are good.
So what are you gonna
sell this year?
You've done $8,000
since the beginning.
$100,000 easily.
The incredible
thing about my product is,
it's not a chachki
because it's functional.
It's something you have
to buy for your children.
And it's ‐‐
Liz, do you ever turn off?
I ‐‐ at night.
When I go to bed.
[ Laughter ]
‐I love that.
‐Or during a movie.
Liz, look. What you've been able
to accomplish is incredible.
You're a force of nature.
But you drive me crazy.
For that reason, I'm out.
[ Sighs ]
I respect you so much.
Thank you for listening.
Thank you.
Liz, I don't know if I see it
in a hairbrush aisle.
I'm not saying you
can't get there.
Yeah.
Keep going.
But not for me
for right now. I'm out.
Okay. I appreciate that, Robert.
And thanks.
I don't see the merit
in this, okay?
I think you're
an interesting person,
you have a lot of energy.
But a year from now,
this is still gonna be
a rhino brush that nobody owns.
It's not even a rhino,
it's a fish.
I disagree with you.
I actually think that every
kid's hairbrush will
look like this in a year.
But I'm not as optimistic
as you on that topic.
Well, he's
so follicly challenged.
[ Laughs ]
And I'm out.
Thank you.
Okay. If you were
to say to me "Buy this.
This is the greatest,"
I would have to buy it
just because I couldn't
turn you away
because of your wild‐ass
enthusiasm.
But the other side
of the wildly enthusiastic is,
you are extremely exhausting.
[ Chuckles ] Yep.
No, and that's
not a bad thing.
But I don't think
anybody's gonna work
the long‐distance
run with you.
So for that reason,
I reluctantly say I'm out.
Barb, I have to just tell you ‐‐
I know when to turn it off.
You guys are seeing
how many pitches?
I've got to sell to you.
I have a very ‐‐
and I don't have numbers.
I don't have numbers
to sell you.
And good for you.
Good for you for recognizing
that and going for it.
So I have to.
Is your husband
exhausted all the time?
No.
Just asking.
He likes me a lot.
I bet he does.
Liz, get focused on the one
Shark that's still in the deal.
I give you, Lori Hairbrush.
‐Hi.
‐Listen, Liz.
I will tell you something
about this brush
that's interesting that I didn't
learn until a year ago.
This is what you call
a wet/dry brush.
The best brush in the world to
brush through any kind of hair.
And it goes right through,
and it doesn't rip it out,
and it doesn't hurt it.
How you got to that,
not being an inventor,
something I didn't know
600 products later,
is amazing to me.
And this is great‐quality plush.
So you have taken
a beautiful plush toy,
put it into the smartest,
best‐working brush there is.
I love the name.
That's adorable.
You have like
the perfect pie here.
So I'm going
to give you an offer.
♪♪
My offer's going
to be aggressive
because you're brand‐new.
Narrator: Four Sharks are out.
Lori is Liz's last chance
for a deal
for her children's hairbrush,
TanglePets.
My offer is going to be
aggressive because
you're brand‐new.
I know I'm going
to have to do a lot.
So I'll give you the $75,000.
We'll be 50/50 partners.
‐Wow.
‐I'll get this into
Buy Buy Baby, QVC.
I, uh, I can't explain how much
of an inspiration you are.
And I know that you're
the perfect partner.
I knew that
walking in here.
But I'm wondering if you'd
at all be willing to go 45%.
I've done this before.
Tremendous amount of work
on my part.
But I'm willing
to give you a hand,
help make a dream come true.
I think I'm the best shot
you've got ever in the world.
I always say ‐‐
I make millionaires.
That's what I do.
Okay, that's what
I wanted to hear!
Lori, you have a deal!
Yay!
And now
I'm turning it back on!
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
Super smart, super good.
You're awesome.
Thank you. Thank you.
You're awesome!
You're Lori!
You all are missing out!
Congrats, Liz.
[ Screams, laughs ]
[ Sobs ]
[ Exhales deeply ]
‐How'd it go?
‐I got a deal with Lori!
‐Yes!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Yeah, I knew it!
‐[ Screams ]
Oh, my God!
♪♪